have you ever played overwatch and
suspected your lower level opponent of
smurfing not sure what smurfing is well
the devious act is when a higher skilled
player makes a new account to compete
against lower skilled players and
overwatch director Jeff Kaplan doesn't
think it's that big of an issue i'm matt
and the skiing spot news update thanks
may players are the real issue smurfing
has become a bit of a sore spot for some
overwatch players and kaplan addressed
recent complaints by letting them know
it's not as big of an issue as they
might think he said the reality is that
skilled players are moved rapidly out of
lower skill situations and that a real
issue is boosting which is when one
highly skilled player tries to carry a
friend into a higher competitive rank
Kaplan says Blizzard is looking into
ways to prevent and punish this along
with other types of deviant behavior
overwatch recently saw the start of a
new event called uprising which features
a new co-op mode and a bunch of awesome
looking skins the new mode has you
playing through the events of tracers
first mission and it'll be available
until the event ends on may first you
can jump in and play right now but if
you just can't wait to check out the new
emotes highlight intros and skins then
watch our archived livestream in which
we shoot some robots and open to loot
boxes
[Music]
you
[Music]